the trump election lawsuits could be
headed for the supreme court and if
they make it to the supreme court if the
court decides to
hear them out they are going to have a
brand new lawyer
giving the oral arguments that very
high-level lawyer would be
senator ted cruz in pennsylvania this
appeal to the supreme court
raises very serious issues it raises
pure issues of law
and and i believe the supreme court
should choose to take the case i think
they should hear the appeal and as you
noted the the legal team
uh reached out and asked if i would be
willing to to
present the oral argument if the court
took the case and i told them i'd be
happy to
because particularly at a time when this
country is so divided when people are so
angry
i think we need a sense of resolution
and and we need the supreme court to
step in and ensure
that we're following the constitution
and following the law right
right now it's not healthy for our
democracy what we're seeing and and
in pennsylvania the problem was made
worse because the pennsylvania supreme
court
is a partisan democratic court that has
issued multiple decisions that that were
just on their face
contrary to law and then that's not how
elections are supposed to work
it all comes down to this at least
in pennsylvania the law is very clearly
on trump's side but there are many other
arguments
involving other states of course this
was the way
the 2020 election had to end of course
this is the way the year
2020 had to end i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday from sean
why are people calling biden the
president-elect when greenland hasn't
even reported their results yet
this is a great question everyone's been
talking about oh we're going to
make puerto rico estate oh we're going
to make washington d.c estate
i've said it from the beginning we need
to make greenland a state
some people are suggesting we could buy
greenland from denmark we could
annex it in that way i think there was a
real missed opportunity when john bolton
was the national security advisor
this is one area where i am totally in
line
with the bush era neocons we needed
shock
and awe in greenland we would have been
greeted as liberators
and now we would have all of those
electoral votes
for president trump i assume i don't
know i don't know very much about
greenland
that would have been the way not just to
ensure
the security of america around the world
but to ensure the security
of our election which a lot of it is
coming down to questions about these
voting machines
very difficult to keep your data secure
very important to understand
how cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives
this holiday season you could miss
certain identity threats by just
monitoring your credit and bank
statements
that's why you need to get a life lock
lifelock is the
leader in identity theft protection
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats such as
your security social security number for
sale on the dark web
if they detect your information being
used in their network they will send you
an
alert if you become a victim of identity
theft lifelock can help restore your
identity
easier than what you can do on your own
i used to think
nobody cares about my data no that's
just for other people
it's not true it's not true and when you
see people deal with identity theft
it can be truly uh upending of of
people's lives no one can monitor and
prevent rather all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but lifelock can help you
feel warm
and protected this holiday season save
up to 25 off your first year by going to
lifelock.com
slash knowles scannerwles that is
lifelock.com
knowles for 25 off
this would be a big deal if
the supreme court agrees to hear the
pennsylvania
election challenge which we should know
very soon
because initially it looked like the
supreme court was not willing to hear
this case out before the deadline to
determine where the electors were going
to go in pennsylvania
then justice sam alito moved that
deadline up to today
so we will know very shortly whether or
not the supreme court is going to deal
with this case
if they do hear this case out you're
going to have
ted cruz give the oral arguments
a lot of people forget but before ted
cruz was a senator before he ran for
president
his job was arguing cases before the
supreme court
he was a very skilled very successful
supreme court litigator
and and so this would be the the
strongest way i think
to to go in and present this case
does that mean that it'll flip the
election not necessarily
but as as i have said from the very
beginning
when one group of people said trump is
definitely going to win and another
group of people said
trump needs to concede right now before
the legal process plays out
there is a constitutional process here
there is a legal process here
president trump should pursue that every
single step he can he should pursue it
right up until
the final deadline when the electors
vote and we we know who the next
president
is going to be and we shouldn't give up
before it's over because here at the
very last moment
there are some big plays going on
that leave a little glimmer of hope hope
springs eternal
in the human breast you've got senator
cruz discussing pennsylvania i have to
wonder by the way
if the reason that the legal team asked
senator cruz to present the oral
arguments
has something to do with the fact that
we dedicated our recent verdict episode
to the legal arguments in pennsylvania
and senator cruz
laid out the entire legal case i don't
know i don't i don't want to
say that they listen to the podcast but
the timing is coincidental and i'm very
pleased
to hear that in addition you've got
questions about michigan you've got
questions about arizona you've got
questions certainly
about georgia sydney powell who is now
best known as the kraken releaser
you know she is not affiliated directly
with the trump legal team the
white house took efforts to distance
themselves
from her a lot of people in the
administration have suggested her claims
are sort of far-fetched
and that they've pursued a different
legal strategy sydney powell however
is still sticking to her guns she went
on television last night to insist
that michigan and arizona should also be
going to the supreme court as well
we also have a case out of michigan that
needs to go
a case out of arizona that may very well
wind up there
there should be at least three states
before the supreme court
with enough electoral votes to change
the outcome before the end of the week
now when people saw this last night i
think a lot of them thought
ah this doesn't sound so real we've been
waiting on the kraken for a few weeks
now we haven't gotten the kraken
things aren't looking so good these
states probably aren't going to the
supreme court
well coincidentally we've just gotten
breaking news in the last 20 minutes
that texas the state of texas
is going to be suing georgia wisconsin
michigan and pennsylvania
how why is this one state suing all
these other states
because texas is alleging and i think we
all know this to be true
that the states had bizarre and
irregular election practices many of
which were unconstitutional
many of which were passed from judicial
benches
or from random election officials or
through executive orders
rather than through the legislatures in
the case of pennsylvania just violated
the constitution outright
and so what texas is saying is this this
violates the elector's clause and it
violates the equal protection clause of
the constitution
you can't have these states all messing
around with how they're conducting the
elections
and not playing by the rules and then
have the other states
playing by the rules and then have all
of that counted equally in an election
that's
broadly what texas is saying what does
this mean
it means that they're suing in the
supreme court
they don't when a when a state sues
another state
there is original jurisdiction in the
supreme court because you can't have a
a state isn't going to sue another state
in a district court a court of appeals
it's going to go all the way up to the
supreme court
will the supreme court care about this
argument i'm not so sure
but this is what it all comes down to
when everyone's been telling you
wait let the process play out the
process is playing out right now i mean
things are changing
every single minute and that's why
patience is a virtue courage is a virtue
and we will know very shortly how this
election is going to turn out
so i'm very pleased the trump legal team
is pursuing every option they've got
however there's a very good chance
that the courts do not give this
election to president trump so what then
the trump administration is doing
everything they can
to make it very difficult for joe biden
to reverse the accomplishments of the
last four years
very prudent very wise don't put all
your eggs in the basket of the supreme
court
you will often be disappointed don't put
all your eggs in the basket of we're
gonna get a second term
you've got to take precautions in case
as it seems there's a very good chance
joe biden becomes the president
so number one up on the docket
president trump has signed an executive
order to make sure that americans get
the coronavirus vaccine first
this this seems obvious right who what
american politician
in the midst of this unprecedented well
it's an unprecedented lockdown i don't
know if you call it an unprecedented
pandemic
but it's an unprecedented lockdown what
american president would say okay we're
going to
pay to develop the vaccine we're going
to lead the world fight on developing
the vaccine
and then we're going to give it to other
people before every american gets it
what american politician would say that
democrats that's who
because the biden plan on the vaccine is
that some americans are going to get the
vaccine
and then they're going to give it away
to the rest of the world and then maybe
some other americans will get it later
president trump says absolutely not
so this executive order says that other
countries
may request shipments of the vaccine
only after the quote
needs of the american people have been
met
this according to a white house official
there are some minor exceptions to this
rule because we've got deals with canada
and things like that but
as a generally speaking americans
according to this executive order will
get the vaccine first
and then the rest of the world can get
it now you might say if if joe biden
becomes president
that executive order won't mean very
much because he can just rip up the
executive
order sometimes that's true sometimes it
isn't
president trump is still not permitted
to rescind some of barack obama's
executive orders
but as we all know the left plays by
different rules than the right does so
joe biden could just rip up the
executive order right
i suppose he could but then he has to
answer politically
for why he is prioritizing the health of
the
rest of the world over that of americans
conservatives have always been a little
skeptical about the experts claims about
this virus and the need for the
lockdowns and everything
about that but the left has not
democrats have said this thing is going
to kill you
don't go outside don't breathe don't see
your family wrap yourself in a bubble
so then that democratic president is
going to go have to go back and say
hey we're not going to let americans get
this first that's going to be very
difficult and and there are a lot of
actions that president trump can take
right now
in case stop biden does become president
to make it very difficult for him
to roll back what the trump
administration has accomplished
it's good to be aggressive it's good to
be ambitious it's good to be courageous
and play this thing out in court
it's also very good to be prepared for
the worst and you know now is a better
time than ever to be prepared with
long-term nutritional food options
from ready-wise ready-wise makes being
prepared simple and affordable
order online get nutritious meals
shipped directly
to your doorstep ready-wise makes being
prepared simple
makes it affordable it's so easy when
preparing ready wise meals all you need
is four cups of water the water doesn't
even need to be hot
you simply pour the food into water stir
and cover
after about 15 minutes the meal is ready
some meals can even be prepared
directly in the pouch which means you
don't need additional supplies
this is peace of mind is what you're
ordering here i don't think
anybody after this year can say oh no
worries nothing will ever go wrong
there's no problem
it's okay it's an ounce of prevention is
worth a pound of cure here okay you
don't want to be in a position where you
don't have food
when resources are strained this week my
listeners can get free shipping at
readywise.com
when entering knowles knwles at checkout
or by calling 855-453-2945
readywise has a 90-day no questions
asked return policy there is no risk
taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family prepared today
readywise r-e-a-d-y-w-ise.com promo code
now scanner wlas
to get free shipping
great executive order from trump another
thing that trump is doing which is
some people might view it as the
opposite of saving lives i don't view it
this way but
while he's trying to make sure americans
get this vaccine he's also ramping up
executions for people on death row which
i think is actually an important way to
save lives but
it's a little bit indirect because
you're saving lives by
by killing criminals who who have been
sentenced to death
if the updated
schedule of the executions is carried
off
president trump would become the most
prolific
execution president in over 130 years i
think this is a very good
thing i know there is disagreement the
left is very anti-death penalty
even many conservatives are anti-death
penalty
i am not anti-death penalty i think the
death penalty is very misunderstood
i think it's very important as a matter
of justice i think as our conceptions
of justice in this country are
completely distorted and perverted and
we replace
real justice with a sort of liberal
bastardization of social justice
i think it's important in a country that
is a free country and has law and order
that we have justice all the way up to
including capital punishment
that that is because there is a
deterrent effect of capital punishment
it's not a very strong effect right now
because people languish on death row for
30 years that's one of the problems
trump is trying to
fix uh there is a
retributive aspect of capital punishment
which is the purpose that is the primary
purpose
of criminal justice the primary purpose
is not rehabilitation the primary
purpose is not deterrence
it is retribution because
someone has committed a crime that's why
it's called justice that's why it's not
called criminal rehabilitation
system or criminal deterrence system
it's called the criminal justice system
give people what they deserve there's
mercy as well we have a pardon power
but there's also justice we can't have
only mercy we can't have only justice
without any mercy
but we need the justice component too
and there's a rehabilitative component
because hanging concentrates the mind
very well
some people are calling for these
executions to be put off nobody's
allowed to
kill the people on death row all these
poor people they committed a crime so
long ago oh it's
they made a mistake let them off the
hook
you notice that the people who are
calling for these executions to be
descheduled and for these criminals to
be pardoned they never talk about the
specifics
when they do talk about specifics they
say he was so young he was 18 when he
committed the crime
or he's black or she's black and so
because they're
they've this particular race you can't
it's bad to execute them or something
they never talk about the crimes very
quickly
bernard brandon bernard this is an
execution scheduled for thursday
the left is in overdrive trying to get
this execution
descheduled we actually mentioned
brandon bernard some months ago on the
show
bernard killed two youth ministers todd
and stacy bagley in killen texas
in 1999 he asked them for a ride he was
hitchhiking these two youth ministers
out of the goodness of their heart pull
over give them a ride
he then takes out a gun he holds them
captive
he beats them he throws them
in the trunk of their own car he then
drives them around for a very long time
as he's spending their money
trying to purchase things selling their
possessions
as they're pleading for their lives
they're reading him scripture
he then shoots them both but he doesn't
end up killing the woman
so then he sets the trunk of the car on
fire and burns her alive
it was so long ago though right come on
he was young
you know we all make mistakes okay we
all
kidnap our benefactors rob them
torture them for hours shoot them and
burn them alive right
we all do we all make that mistake come
on what kind of a just country
would execute that man uh i think age
any just country would execute that man
and a country that has no sense of
justice would deschedule that execution
alfred bourgeois tortured and killed his
two-year-old daughter
whom he regularly abused physically and
sexually
he killed her because he had a brief
moment of custody when his his the
mother of this daughter lost custody
just a very brief time uh he killed her
because
she tipped over her potty training chair
in his flatbed truck
so he slammed her head into a truck
window killed her
oh we have come on it was so long ago
come on what kind of a just country
would kill that man
any just country corey johnson murdered
seven people seven people
uh spurred uh into this crime because he
wanted to further his drug trafficking
operation
he ended up killing his intended victims
family members and acquaintances too so
it wasn't even just other people
involved in the drug trafficking ring
customers who didn't pay which were some
of his victims or
other rival drug traffickers wasn't even
just them it was also
family members and acquaintances oh no
he only killed seven people he only
ended seven lives
come on we we would be so awful if we if
we
killed him dustin john higgs kidnapped
and murdered three women this was
premeditated this was in cold blood
and finally lisa montgomery who
strangled a pregnant woman to death you
might remember this story he was very
famous at the time bobby joe stinnett
she strangled a pregnant woman to death
cut open her body kidnapped her baby
but that was so long ago right that's
part of the problem
that's part of the problem
this has gone on too long frankly i
think that
i don't think that the capital
punishment by any measure could be
called cruel and unusual punishment
it's not it's never been unusual in the
entire history of the world and it's not
particularly
cruel compared to say life in prison i
think that is
as a historical fact that is unusual
and i think that is cruel part of the
reason that we
have lost our sense of justice here is
because we've gone from being a
christian culture to being a materialist
culture
so we now believe that the worst thing
that can possibly happen to someone
is physical death because we have no
sense of uh the spirit of the soul
of the eternal moral order so now we
just think it's all about flesh and meat
the minute you die it's the worst thing
that could possibly happen
i don't think that's necessarily true
i think there are things worse than
physical death and it's i think it's
very important
that president trump continue on his
path and ramp up these executions
if these people languish on death row
too long the answer to that is not to
pardon all of them
it's to kill them faster this
is a you see you see the defenses of
capital punishment
not just in scripture not just in moral
philosophy but we know them
intuitively that this is not a demand
for revenge we're not saying vigilante
should go out and kill their enemies
the state has a role in exacting justice
and it ain't just giving out parking
tickets it goes all the way up good
stuff from president trump because by
the way if these are delayed in any way
and if biden does become president then
he's going to have to deschedule
these he's going to have to explain why
these
monsters should be pardoned
why these monsters should not receive
they're just punishment
he's going to have to explain that to
the victims and the victims fame no i
guess not the victims but to the victims
families something else going on right
now if
joe biden becomes president as he seems
certain that he will
even though the supreme court has not
heard these cases yet
he has announced that he wants someone
named
xavier becerra to be the director of
health or the secretary of health and
human services
for those who don't know because i was
just living in la la land uh
becerra is the attorney general for
california becerra is one of the worst
elected officials in the entire country
his
career has been spent attacking pro-life
people
they've been attacking friends of mine
uh david deliden
who is who was attacked because he
exposed the fact that planned parenthood
sells baby body parts on the open market
he was attacked actually not just by
becerra but but by
kamala harris as well who could be the
vice president
his he's fanatically opposed to unborn
babies he
he's fanatically in favor of abortion
he's an unacceptable
nominee if if there is a biden
presidency
his nomination is completely
unacceptable tom cotton made this point
he said that
he should be rejected by the senate i'll
do cotton one better
all republicans in the senate should
vote against becerra
if there's abiding administration and
he's nominated
any republican that does not vote
against becerra
should be primaried and removed from
office
the candidate is completely unacceptable
when i pointed this out yesterday on
social media
someone responded to me and said michael
that's so hypocritical
so how's that hypocritical he says
because
this is the kind of thing democrats did
to trump
they held up trump's nominees for
certain positions and so
we can't then if we didn't like that
then we can't go ahead
and hold up democrat nominees for for
certain positions
i think people misunderstand what
hypocrisy means
is good to stop
bad democratic nominations
it is bad to stop good
republican nominations republicans and
democrats are
different they have a different vision
of the country
i think some people are are holding
themselves over
from decades ago when republicans and
democrats
usually weren't all that different when
there was a great similarity
and they weren't particularly
conservative
it's a holdover from this this old now i
think
dead idea that all of politics is just
about procedure
for instance we can't stop drag queen
story hour we can't stop
people from twerking in front of
four-year-olds in their classrooms or
libraries
because if we tell them they can't do
that they might tell us we can't go to
church
they might tell us we can't watch monday
night football i don't if we don't allow
them
to to have whatever sort of institution
or association they want
they might tell us we can't have
whatever institution or association we
want
no no that the founding fathers are
rolling over in their graves hearing
that idea
they're not all the same the getting
back to our point on the death penalty
or getting back to the federalist papers
james madison
the end of government is justice
the end of government is not letting
people do whatever they want all the
time the end of government is
justice well how do we define justice
using our brains that's how we define
justice using
the moral order and our moral intuitions
and our faculties of reason
we can come to understand justice if we
do not have the ability to discern
between good and bad then we can't have
self-government anyway
so please spare me these ridiculous
ideas
that anything democrats do and anything
republicans
it's all sort of the same it's not these
are different things and we have to
fight over the issues
themselves and we absolutely need to
stop
becerra you know these moves from the
trump administration
are a sort of insurance policy he's
still going to fight in court to try to
get a second term
but you need a little bit of an
insurance policy and
one insurance policy that i really like
is car shield because you won't get
stuck with another high repair bill
car shield offers affordable protection
that can save you thousands
on repairs whether your car has 5 000
miles or 150 000 miles
car shield has a protection plan for
everyone payments are flexible
plans are customizable to your exact
needs you can take your car to your
favorite mechanic or dealership
to do the work and car shield gets the
rest taken care of
car shield has helped over one million
drivers that's why they are america's
number one
auto protection company you know i now
live in a place that has weather
i didn't before i lived in a place that
had climate before but not weather
you know sometimes there are different
things things can scratch up your car
things can get your car into all sorts
of trouble you need repairs you hit the
thing in the road the thing breaks
you know listen i'm obviously not a
professional mechanic myself but i just
call them the thing
drive with confidence like i do knowing
that if anything happens you're
protected get coverage today and see why
car shield cars
go farther visit car shield dot com use
code knowles k-w-l-e-s
to save ten percent car shield dot com
code knowles
to save ten percent what is that address
it's carshield.com what's the code
knowles
a deductible may apply
now on the public health front speaking
of health and human services
the left is still pushing these
ridiculous lockdown orders
i think i have now heard the most
coherent pro-argument lockdown
from this entire many months-long fiasco
this comes from a public school teacher
she was driving down the street in her
car and i i felt she articulated this
better than just about anybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
i
wow very persuasive very very persuasive
this is who is teaching our students i
actually do think it's
exactly as persuasive as everything
newsom or cuomo or any of these other
people say
at least she's being honest about how it
has no basis in
rational thought and it's just purely
emotional
getting back to our prior discussion
there's this
silly holdover idea that the
liberal culture the secular culture is
neutral it's just neutral okay and we
can never
suggest we can never impose our views
on anybody else we conservatives and you
know the left is there
because if we impose our views then the
left is going to impose their views
i think they're imposing them i'm pretty
sure that's a public school teacher
i'm pretty sure she's imposing her views
if maybe she was having a bad day but i
think
that's pretty good evidence of what
you're getting in classrooms and you're
seeing this all around
the country it's not just on the stupid
lockdown stuff it's on the 1619 project
which is being taught all around the
country
anti-historical trash that
is designed purely to get students to
hate their
hate their country and sometimes
conservatives misunderstand this
because conservatives they they say look
we want education not
indoctrination those words mean
basically the same thing indoctrination
comes from the latin word dochere which
means
to teach
you'll occasionally hear people say we
don't teach students what to think we
just want to teach them how to think
that's not possible all education is
coercive
you don't need to look like that crazy
teacher but you do need to teach people
things you can't teach people how to
think unless you teach them what to
think you can't teach people how to
think about mathematics
unless you teach them the fact that two
plus two equals four
and a student might come to you and say
well i wanna believe that two plus two
equals five well
you're not allowed to believe that you
ha i have to coerce you to believe
the two plus two equals four if i hope
to teach you how to think
the left gets this the left understands
that education is coercive
the right needs to get that too it's not
merely enough to say hey
in addition to your blm curriculum where
you're reading
kenny's stupid book about anti-racism or
you're reading the 1619 project which is
fiction but that's being presented as
history in addition to that would you
mind reading shakespeare
it's not enough to say that you have to
say don't read the 1619 project
take it out of the curriculum don't read
ibram kendi's stupid book
take it out of the curriculum by the way
you have to do that anyway because
there's only so much time
there are only so many semesters there's
only so many days in the week
we've got to get much more serious about
that
if we want to avoid that teacher
shaping the next generation which is
currently happening some people are
pushing back
right now though there's a wonderful guy
in staten island doing that which we'll
get to in one second but i don't know if
you've noticed this on my desk
if you're watching the show right now
instead of listening to it this would be
the brand new and improved
leftist years tumblr you can keep those
leftist ears hot or cold in a new
stainless steel design with a custom
daily wire lid you can see right there
it's got the dw on the lid
most importantly all dishwasher safe
i've had these tumblers obviously since
they were invented
and i've been guzzling leftist tears out
of them the entire time
after you use them for a few years
though those old ones especially if you
put them in the dishwasher which you
weren't supposed to do but obviously i
did anyway it starts to chip it doesn't
look as good
now dishwasher safe oh baby join daily
wire today or upgrade your membership
to get yours just in time to enjoy those
salty tears while watching all of our
new content we got the prageru library
coming
to daily wire including my show the book
club at prageru
we've got candace owens getting her very
own show early next year
on top of all those great deals we have
the daily wire christmas ornaments so
hang us from your tree
head on over to daily wire right now
subscribe
we'll be right back with a lot more
some people are pushing back on this
stuff some people are
saying no screeching leftist teacher in
a car
we're not going to acquiesce to your
will especially
in my home state of new york new york
gets a bad rap because there are a ton
of libs in manhattan
and especially out in brooklyn these
days there's actually only one borough
of new york which is conservative and
that would be staten island
so you'll recall we played this on the
show yesterday
staten island native pete davidson on
snl made
fun of business owners and customers
who refuse to go along with the
lockdowns and lose their livelihoods and
lose their businesses
and lose everything that they've worked
for lose their life savings very often
he made fun of them he said they're
babies they're not manly come on just go
sit at home do whatever the government
says
i don't know go work on zoom right
classic
liberal elite rejoinder to
lockdown protests they say come on just
go look telecommute
just hop on your zoom and commute into
your job at mckinsey
what's so hard what what you need to
leave the house to go to work
what is this the 1850s yeah a lot of
people have to leave the house to go to
work buddy
a staten island activist john tobacco
who actually knows
the king of staten island pete
davidson's father who died on 9 11.
he came out and he he did not mince
words
about this kind of argument about these
people who have been hurt by the
lockdowns
you have mega millionaires who are on
the national spotlight
like the folks on saturday night live um
and instead of making fun of their
friends and the local business owners
who are broke
and crushed and bankrupt instead of
coming down here
as fellow staten islanders and standing
up for them and bringing a positive
light to this thing
what they want to do is go on national
tv and try to humiliate the little man
when he's down
and to me that's quite disgusting and as
i mentioned before my dad was a member
of the nypd
the king of staten island's dad was a
proud fireman and a great friend of mine
and i saw staten islanders heavily come
out and support him
his mom his family and everyone else
in a time of need after 9 11 when i
cried for his father
so when i hear stuff like this it hits
me emotionally when i think wow
if you came out of your perch in your
affluent neighborhood
and came down here and told the liberal
left this is a good thing because it's
about our freedom and liberty
we probably wouldn't be standing here
today
absolutely well put i couldn't have said
it any better myself
talk about babies who do you think is
manlier the liberals scoffing
at the lockdown protesters or that guy i
would not want to meet that guy
in a dark alley in the middle of the
night okay i would not want to get into
a fight
with that guy obviously that's the case
i was thinking
about 2020 a lot of liberal
wealthy friends of mine have complained
about how terrible the year has been
and for them it has been terrible
because they've locked themselves in
their homes for no reason for the whole
year
they've refused to go do anything many
of them have canceled weddings they've
canceled
their holidays they canceled
thanksgiving their cancer they're not
going anywhere and so they have had a
difficult year a lonely year where a
social creature were meant to interact
with one another
that is very difficult but that is a
problem of their own making
the reason that those wealthy liberals
have had a bad year
is because they have acted in a stupid
and foolish way they could have had a
good year
i feel i've had a relatively good year
especially because i got to move out of
california
moved to tennessee so now i can breathe
the sweet air of freedom again
but i do feel i've had a pretty good
year there have been difficult moments
of it and there's
been some hits obviously the economy
took a hit for almost everybody
but generally speaking i've had a decent
enough time
fortunately daily wires been able to
keep a roof on it over our heads so
that's a good thing right
all of these wealthy liberals their
companies are doing fine and nbc is
doing fine
snl is doing fine so i want to say
it's your own fault if you're having a
bad year but that's not true for
everybody there are a lot of other
people who are having a bad year
and it's no fault of theirs whatsoever a
lot of other people are having a bad
year because they lost their job
because of these policies
pointless senseless medically incoherent
policies
that guys on snl and in the liberal
media
are applauding making fun of us for not
cheering on ourselves
those policies have ruined lives
they've made people die alone they've
made people lose relatives and friends
never getting to say goodbye they've
made people not even
be allowed to have funerals for their
dead loved ones they've made people push
off
weddings they've made people put their
lives
on hold often losing what little money
they'd scrape together to start a small
business
some people losing their life savings
that's that's not their fault
that is the fault it is somebody's fault
it's not only it's not only the virus's
fault it's not only the chinese
government's world
it is the fault of andrew cuomo
and gavin newsom and eric garcetti
and nancy pelosi and
a lot of these and lori lightfoot
chicago it is the fault of people
who have made specific political
decisions that have hurt a lot of people
it might not hurt pete davidson but it's
hurt
a lot of other people around the country
what's what's manly is it manly to make
fun of those people
hahaha he said no i don't think so i
think
the manly thing to do the virtuous thing
to do is stand
up push back live your life don't live
your life in fear
and stop these politicians from running
roughshod over your lives
speaking of manliness you remember this
story that became a national news story
the other day
because a girl kicked a football
at a vanderbilt football game and this
was a huge news story because the
vanderbilt football team is men
but then a woman kicked a football one
time during the game and so that's a
huge deal
so vanderbilt is really playing this up
the whole team is really playing this up
there's now a small little feature
that's been produced about this girl
kicking the football and here's what the
gal has to say about this historic
moment
when i was younger it used to be an
insult
kids would come up and say oh you play
like a girl we are about to witness
history
in college football when you see someone
else who looks like you who's lived a
life like you who's
had a background like you you know that
i can do that too
i want to change that narrative and show
that like playing a
girl is a compliment is something you
want to strive for
i do not want to make fun of this girl
it's very nice that she got to kick the
football during the game and i guess
it's probably pretty impressive
you know relatively speaking
how do i put this in a nice way the fact
that this girl
kicked a football during a game with
boys
does not change anything about sports
or biology or
competition it doesn't it doesn't change
that at all
this little video begins it says you
know people used to
say if you kick like a girl you know
then you're not as strong as if you kick
like a boy
but now we're gonna change that no you
won't
because the boys still kick the ball
further the boys are still better at
sports because the boys are physically
stronger because the boys are different
than the girls
it's not a knock on girls it's just a
fact we talked about
the story of karsten brosh the other day
there was a they when this kind of issue
cropped up in the 90s there was the
battle of the sexes
venus and serena williams said they
could beat any man at tennis ranked
outside the top 200. so this guy shows
up he was ranked like 203 or something
smokes a pack of cigarettes drinks a
couple beers plays a round of golf shows
up and he beats the sisters six to one
and six to two
it's not making fun of the sisters
they're very good female tennis players
but
women are physically less strong than
men
and it's not going to be helpful to
women to pretend and delude them into
thinking that they are physically
as strong as men because if a woman
finds herself in a dangerous situation
with a man
and vastly overestimates her strength
she's
not going to be thanking the people who
pushed that ridiculous ideology on them
then as some people from the football
team gave us a little insight into the
the moment on the field apparently some
of the men
on the sidelines they were so touched
and moved they were crying
there were some people on the sideline
tearing up like just the and then the
emotion in the crowd
everybody cheering on everybody was
excited the entire stadium was electric
[Music]
the men on the sidelines were crying
because a girl kicked the ball something
tells me they were also crying
when the team lost the game 41 to
nothing
that's another inconvenient fact about
this great story that they're probably
going to make a feature film out of now
they lost the game they didn't get a
single point
it's nice for the girl we can't we be
can we say oh that's nice for the girl
that she got this opportunity to
kick the ball in the men's football game
and not pretend that
biology has suddenly been upended that
now this is some magnificent advance for
the human species
that now women now what if women are as
physically strong as men
what that means is when little boys are
taught never hit a girl they can't be
taught that anymore right
why men and women are exactly the same
they're equally strong why not you
men should never hit a girl because
women are the gentler sex
weaker sex physically
that all remains true i think these men
now might be a much weaker sex
than they used to be if they're crying
on the sidelines because a girl kicked a
football one time
speaking of tearing up by the way there
is something far more amiss in our
culture than college football
the left has so infiltrated institutions
so
hollowed out our most beloved rituals
and traditions
that now you have shopping mall santa
clauses you know you bring the kid up
and you take a picture and the kid says
what he wants for christmas
you now have woke shopping mall santa
clauses
telling little boys that he won't get
them the presents
that they want because they're not
politically correct
kids sitting there saying this across
the table because i guess social
distancing now i don't know
he doesn't know what he wants what do
you want come on kid
what
no i don't know guns he said he wants a
nerf gun
nope not even a nerf gun
if your dad wants to get it for you
that's fine but i can't bring it to you
but what else would you like
lots of other toys there's legos what
bicycles
santa tells the kid he won't get the kid
a nerf gun
it's not even a bb gun like in that
movie you'll shoot your eye out kid
it's a nerf gun it shoots someone point
blank with a nerf gun it's not going to
do anything
now the kid starts to cry because santa
claus told him he can't get the one toy
he wants
what a sicko this guy is crying
[Music]
don't cry i can make a donation in your
name to planned parenthood
come on i'll get you what every kid
wants i'll get you a biden harris bumper
sticker
and the kid's crying yeah
i love that mother i love that yeah
you'll still get it don't don't worry
we're still gonna get you the gun
because this
shmucky santa claus over here first of
all the that santa claus isn't gonna
bring the kid anything
because that santa claus is a guy
working a seasonal job at a
at a shopping mall if that guy shows up
at this woman's house the police are
gonna get called
but he can't even say okay johnny sure
we'll get you a nerf gun this year
no he says no i we can't do that
because if look if you get a nerf gun
then that means you'll have some fun
and you can't have any fun we're not
allowed to do that anymore but also
then one day you might want to have a
real gun
which means that you might exercise your
second amendment rights
and we can't have that because you know
we because the constitution
that's not that's not in the spirit of
holiday cheer so sorry johnny you're
getting cold this year
what a sicko who does this who allows
a political ideology to so warp their
mind
and soul that they take a job as a mall
store santa claus
and make a little kid cry at christmas
now of course this is this is the
defining feature of political
correctness
political correctness seeks to upend
every old standard every old
tradition every old institution it seeks
in marx's words the ruthless
criticism of all that exists you often
hear political correctness described in
the same breath
as critical theory which is a sort of
academic field that developed in the
20th century
well what's the the theory is to
criticize that's critical theory in a
nutshell is to criticize everything
and it derives from this idea that you
have to ruthlessly criticize all that
exists including
these beloved holiday traditions
a joyless leftist scold does not know
the time and place and does not know his
place does not know his job does not
have a sense of his
duty which is to go and make the kid
feel good and take a picture
at christmas that is
a a total inversion of the way things
ought to be
and it's a glimpse of the future under
political correctness you know we've had
a very lovely
four years that were that was a break
from political correctness trump in many
ways
launched his campaign against political
correctness he said that he said i don't
have time for political correctness
political correctness is absolutely
killing this country
and the possible election of joe biden i
guess we'll soon find out
is not the election of some new vision
for the country it's just a return
to that politically correct corrosive
movement
that is slowly decaying every single
thing that we like in this country
and often it doesn't even matter who
gets elected it's just for some reason
it keeps running its course
through the culture that sort of stuff
is at stake joe biden is not going to
know what end is up
if he becomes president but all those
joyless leftists those bureaucrats those
radicals that he's already talking about
appointing
to his cabinet all those people are
going to be shaping our country
and they can have an outsized effect and
so we hold out hope
we wait to hear from the supreme court
hope springs eternal in the human breast
and we'll know a lot more tomorrow i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show see you then
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadovsky editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer mike coromina hair and
makeup by nika geneva
and production assistant mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. you know the
matt walsh show
it's not just another show about about
politics i think there are enough of
those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen